- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems of the world.
So today's message is
don't be afraid of losses.
Over to you, Robert Kiyosaki.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- Well most successful
entrepreneurs have gone bust.
You know, Henry Ford, an
old-time entrepreneur,
he went bust five times.
Okay, look at Steve Jobs.
- [Interviewer] Yep.
- His own board fired him.
- Bill Gates, was taken
before the Supreme Court
for monopolistic practices.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Even my friend, Donald Trump,
went down a billion dollars.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I only went down a million.
So, the average person is
so afraid of those losses
they never get ahead.
Because at school, they teach
you if you make a mistake
or if you fail, you're a failure.
But that's not real life.
A baby learns to walk by
standing up and falling down,
standing up and falling down.
And our school system punishes
you for making mistakes.
That's why my poor dad, an
academic, was so unsuccessful.
He was terrified of making mistakes.
- Most people are so afraid to lose
that they don't even try.
We have these big dreams, big ambitions,
big projects we want to work on.
And here's the mind twist.
This is why it's so hard.
It's so fun to think
about where we can go.
It's so fun to think about
my channel at a million subscribers.
It's so fun to think
about you on that beach
or you owning that car, you
having that big business,
you having that big impact.
It's so amazing, in our heads,
of that life that we want to live.
But doing the work actually is hard.
And especially at the beginning,
when you create your first
thing, it's going to suck.
And you're afraid of how people
are going to react to it.
The judgment from your
friends, from your parents,
from the people around you, who look at it
and say, "That's not very good."
And as soon as you start making that
and you get the negativity
and the criticism,
also from yourself, knowing
that what you made sucked.
It starts to eat away at that dream.
You start to think that big
dream is not possible anymore.
And so what ends up
happening to so many people
is they just stop.
They just don't do any work.
They don't take any more action.
Because they can stay in their head
and just imagine about the one day
this thing is going to happen.
Cause it sets off the endorphins.
It makes you happy.
But doing the work is painful
and stressful and negative
and, again, every time
you do it, it cracks away
at you actually thinking
that big dream is possible.
If you don't do any work, you
can just stay in your head
and stay happy.
But what's going to happen?
It's kind of like some of those movies,
where you know what's going to happen,
or those puzzles where you
know what the answer is.
You don't want to do the puzzle anymore.
The excitement is just in
figuring out the problem.
And so, it's really exciting
to figure out a problem.
I know how to solve this problem.
Here's what Google should do.
Here's what McDonald's should do.
Here's what Coca-Cola should do.
I know how to solve
their business problem.
It's really fun thinking
through the exercise
of solving the problem.
But actually doing the work sucks.
And so people don't do the work.
They just stay up in their head.
You need to learn to stop that.
You need to learn to be patient.
You need to learn to do the work.
You need to learn to actually go out
and accomplish the big thing
that you want to accomplish,
the big thing that you say
is so important to you,
to get it out of your head
and start taking the
action to make it happen.
Because we all have these dreams.
Everybody has a dream.
Everybody wants more out of life.
Everybody wants to have
a greater contribution.
But most of us are not mapping our actions
to go achieving those dreams.
You're not taking the
daily, consistent action
to make it happen.
And so you need to, every single day,
take some kind of action,
move closer to your goal.
Expect to suck.
Expect to be criticized by yourself,
your own hatred of your own work,
as well as the people around you.
That's normal.
That's to be expected.
Anticipate that.
Because if you go in thinking big dream
and then your first thing sucks
and then you get depressed and you quit,
that's not going to help.
Expect to suck.
Expect the next one to
suck a little bit less,
next one to suck a little bit less,
and taking daily, consistent action
so you can get out of your head
and start actually accomplishing things.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what was the first thing you did
to take that big dream that you had
and actually take some action
on it and implement it?
What was the first action
item that you took?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Eric.
Eric, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really
appreciate the support, man
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So, thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you!
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is!
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- Failure is part of life.
I mean, the difference for me, though
is I look at failure as a
stepping stone to success.
It's a speed bump.
I know I'm going to fail
but it's not failure
if you learn something.
And so, gosh, I've made so many mistakes,
I've screwed so many things up.
But every time I do, it just becomes,
it becomes a way for me
to explain to someone else what it takes.
You know, it's like,
here's what I've done.
I think I have the ability
to influence people
'cause I talk about my failures.
I talk about all the
things that mess me up.
But I show people that
I didn't let it stop me
and you don't need to let it stop you.
And I think that's really
the secret in that area.
- And if everything you
touch was successful,
You probably weren't going
to relate to people as much.
- No, you're not going to be relate
and also it's total bullsh--
and everyone know it's bullsh--
and, also, you'd be bored silly!
I mean, think about it.
If you just said I want
this and it happened,
I want this and it happened,
you know, people don't value
what they don't fight for.
You know, it's like
you see kids sometimes,
you know, your parents will say,
"You're not going to value
this if you don't work for it."
And you're a kid going, "I'll
value it, just give it to me."
(laughing)
But it's true, you know,
about the things we've
worked the hardest for,
we value the most.
So, I think, you know,
the purpose of a goal
is not getting it anyway.
The purpose of a goal is who you become.
Who you become is going to make you happy
or it's going to make you sad.
So, I'm not looking for
an effortless approach.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- There's no such thing.
- You should seek failures.
See, if you're playing it
safe, you're not going to win.
If you're playing it safe,
like that old saying,
you know, you're taught
when you're a little girl,
better to be safe than sorry.
Well, that's a bunch of crap.
It's not better to be safe than sorry.
It's by trying things that you figure out
how far you can go.
You got to get outside the box.
Like it's reported,
Edison tried 3,000 ways
before he built the incandescent light.
He said, he didn't fail 3,000 times.
He said there was 3,000 different steps
to building a light bulb.
Well there's different steps
to get to where you're going.
And I really do treat winning
and losing exactly the same.
I do not let it upset me.
- Do you think that's
a big part of why you're so successful?
- Well, it's part of why I enjoy it.
Yeah, I think it is.
'Cause I try anything.
Like, if I'm into an idea,
the idea of losing never enters my mind.
See, I have worked with giants.
I had the good fortune of
working with Sir Edmund Hillary.
He was the first man to
stand on top of the world.
And I worked with him on
three different occasions.
And the only difference in Ed Hillary
and Bob Proctor is his size.
Now, he's gone now but he was a big man.
When he shook hands with me,
his hand wrapped right around mine.
I felt like a dwarf, you know.
And talking to him, like
it never entered his mind
he wouldn't get to the
top of the mountain.
But he failed in 1951, he failed in 1952.
It wasn't until 1953 that he
got to the top of the mountain.
People had died for
centuries trying to do that.
But he said, "I know if
I can see it in here,
I could hold it out here."
Stella Mann wrote that in a book.
You can see it in your head,
you can hold it in your hand.
And that's right.
And if you're not prepared to lose,
you're never going to win 'cause
you're always playing it safe.
And there's no reward in that.
- Yeah, I think failure
is the highway to success.
And I know that sounds like a platitude
but society or people teach us, right?
They say, "Oh, if you fail
and feel uncomfortable,
you've done something wrong."
And what I try to do in all of my books
and my presentations and my tweets
is you cannot get to the mountaintop
without taking a few missteps.
And so, a business that wants to win,
you have to out fail your competition.
And as human beings, you know,
failure is not a bad thing.
You know, ask yourself,
what's the opportunity from the failure?
And get in the game
because when you get to the
last hour of your last day,
it will not be the failures you regret.
It'll be all the risks you didn't take.